WordPress is coming with something
that's that's going to be I think much
better at achieving that concept it's
this Gutenberg editor that's coming to
WordPress course or in a certain level
it is like a really nice-looking WYSIWYG
it gives you bold and italic text you
can change colors of things a really
nice detail here is when you change the
color of text to something that's bad
for accessibility you get a warning
saying this is a bad color choice for
accessibility it's a better fulfillment
than just the idea of a
what-you-see-is-what-you-get editor so
rather than having that shortcode block
that we just have to imagine what it's
going to look like rather than trying to
imagine what our drupal paragraph might
look like on the other side we can just
see the google map that we're dealing
with this is a plug-in that Andrew wrote
for Google Maps embedding right into the
WYSIWYG adding images as incredibly easy
one detail on a point out here is that
to add the image block I'm not pressing
the button for the block I'm just using
a keyboard shortcut to say own an image
and then I decided no actually I want a
gallery of images I'm going to convert
this image block to a gallery block and
then just upload a bunch of images at
once I've been saying the word block a
couple times here that's the key concept
in Gutenberg everything is a block each
paragraph is a block block quote is a
block the map is a block and so on you
can have blocks inside of other blocks
nesting of blocks similar to the way you
can have paragraph paragraphs in Drupal
nested inside of other paragraph
entities some blocks are static blocks
meaning a heading a paragraph tag a
block quote what you might imagine of
that HTML is just what's directly saved
into the database in WordPress some
blocks are dynamic basically I'm saying
here I want a a block of recent posts
rather than the default 5 I want
specifically 6 recent posts and I want
to display it in two columns instead of
one so it's getting saved into the
database is recent posts six of them and
two columns what we see in the editor
here is a react block like react is used
for the editor itself react is talking
to the WordPress REST API in order to
give us this rendering inside the editor
but when it gets rendered out to the
general public its server-side
processing of just that idea of
recent posts six of them two columns
that's getting processed server-side you
can have reusable blocks basically I
have a block quote about blocks that I'm
designating to be a reusable block I can
then embed that in other posts updated
in one place and will update everywhere
you can lock down post types basically
the WordPress equivalent of content
types and my first reaction to this was
wait whoa whoa whoa too much flexibility
I need to lock things down while you of
course you can lock things down for the
post types or it makes sense to lock
things down the data model is almost
going to almost certainly going to be
the most controversial choice the data
model is the body filled WordPress
treasures the body field it considers
that you know nearly sacred and its
importance so what we see here is that
each block ends up getting saved as
basically the HTML that that is the
rendered representation of the block
that gets delineate Aditi al comments
the HTML comments say what the block
type is there may be some JSON within
the HTML comment and the reason they're
doing this is because they think this
makes the the body field more
comprehensible more my gradable more
ownable it's a better fulfillment of the
idea of democratizing publishing there
could be technical advantages to you
know storing each block as its own
database record and they've written the
they've written the editor in such a way
that the serialization the saving could
be swappable so you could just store
this as JSON you could just store this
as its own records in the database block
by block but for democratizing
publishing they want the default to just
be the whole bit of HTML all right with
that I'm going to turn things over to
Andrew to talk more about how exactly
did they get here from from a technical
perspective yeah thanks Steve
so this has been a long time coming in
WordPress so I kind of wanted to share
with you the journey of JavaScript
adoption this isn't something that
happened overnight this happened over a
long period of time
WordPress actually has a different
feature besides the Gutenberg editor
called the customizer where basically
you have configuration over on the
left in that pain and on the right you
get a live preview this is a fully
JavaScript driven application or users
can go and update the settings see that
live preview on the right you can drag
and drop things you can do all of this
really cool stuff and it first came into
core
back in 2012 in WordPress 3.4 so it's
been there quite a long time core uses
it a fair bit end-users like that they
can go in and update their logo and
things like this and see the preview
without having to publish and then go
look at the front-end of their site gets
rid of that save in surprise but
developer adoption was not very high
with the customizer so in 2015 they made
it required that any theme uploaded to
the official repository had to use theme
settings within the customizer rather
than their own settings page and
developers did that but they just sort
of did only that that was the bare
minimum that's all they did even though
they had this great javis clip
JavaScript application that was
extensible and they could do all kinds
of really neat things with it here we
can see things you could like lazy load
items so if I wanted to build a slider
on the home page I could have a button
so clients could dynamically add slides
and upload images and see how it's going
to look before they publish but nobody
really did that outside of a few
enterprise projects where clients would
foot the bill for that custom
development there weren't a lot of
contributing on in the community taking
advantage of this and then in late 2015
automatic the company sort of behind
wordpress.com which is a commercial
product built Calypso which was a react
native alternative interface for the
WordPress administrative experience um
it ran Mac Windows Linux you could fire
it up you could connect your sites to it
you could publish all your content in it
in this nice sort of native app way and
it's you see here much different looking
than kind of the editor we've been
seeing previously and so people thought
wow this is you know going to be a
complete game-changer maybe this will
come into
WordPress core and things like that but
no no adoption some folks that use the
dot-com commercial product used it a few
other sites you had to install jetpack
which is also done by automatic kind a
large company in the space you had to
connect to their API is to use this
product and people didn't really adopt
it so WordPress has been trying to get
JavaScript into core with these
experiences for quite some time and
after Calypso still in 2015 the state of
the word which is similar to the Driss
note happens at WordCamp us in december
every year matt mullenweg sort of the
the leader of wordpress just gave a
homework assignment learned javascript
deeply and people like okay javascript
is you know kind of surging and taking
over the web and a lot of spaces and be
like well what do I learn what's going
on and so they had this kind of
directive but didn't really know what to
do with it and then in December 2016
he said he's putting back the product
lead hat putting the product lead hat
back on as Steve talked about WordPress
went from a release cycle every four
months to Matt kind of said hey I'm
taking over we're not gonna do releases
anymore it's just gonna be done when
it's done so this was 2016 and the only
idea we had of the new editor was this
one slide at the keynote that said it
will be block based and it will replace
widgets and short codes and all the
other things we have going on is so it's
gonna be this cool new thing that will
take care of all of it and people kind
of went what what's going on right we're
supposed to learn JavaScript very deeply
this thing is coming to core but now the
community doesn't have as much control
we don't have input we're not having a
community release lead the head of
automatic is taking back over and we
don't know what's coming or wind pretty
scary stuff right and so even though
there was this homework assignment to
learn JavaScript deeply we had react and
babble and es6 and web pack and all
these things come out and people are
kind of learning it but not for
WordPress people were doing WordPress
we're slow to adopt this there are a
couple people that had third-party
plugins and things that maybe they would
rewrite their plug-in admin screen in
view or react or something because it
was cool and they wanted to play with it
but overall the white adoption was not
there and so there was this big question
mark around JavaScript and WordPress we
knew something was coming we knew this
editor was coming but people didn't know
what they had to do when things are
gonna be released and all that stuff so
there was a little bit of this bumpy
road WordPress actually threw around its
weight a bit against Facebook and they
wanted to use react to drive these
JavaScript experiences but it was not
licensed to be open source friendly and
finally Facebook kind of blinked first
and they rely scense react with the MIT
license so that it is open source
compatible and they started publishing
documentation so this is an examples of
what this is going to look like so this
is a screenshot here we have some
documentation on the development stuff
going under the hood but it was really a
big chunk of developers from automatic
with Matt leading this charge in doing a
lot of this development and it was on
github but it still didn't have a lot of
involvement and people couldn't quite
see what was going on and so as we move
further down the road they release some
tools WordPress has a command line
called WP CLI similar to Josh so you
could scaffold a plug-in and create your
own custom block in him that worked well
for developers but it still didn't reach
that wider audience and so there's still
this kind of you know what's going on
here and then at state of the word in
December just last year you can kind of
see the quote here they did a live demo
where the technical lead for the
Gutenberg Project got on stage and
actually said in the mic I just pulled a
bunch of in-progress branches together I
hope this works can you imagine the head
of the DRI's note and so came in gave
this like really solid 15-minute live
demo live streamed and
the whole audience everything that
showed it off and people saw kind of the
power of what Steve was showing this new
content authoring experience and they
got really excited it was announced that
WordPress was going to continue this
focus that there's still no set release
you still need to learn JavaScript
deeply and Gutenberg is here to stay it
was this very loud message and people
finally said okay we're going to pay
attention now that live demo was sort of
the turning point when the community
kind of went I don't know what's going
on it was very very clear after this
state of the word presentation what was
going on in that you need to adopt
Gutenberg because this was coming and so
the community reacted and they got
behind it I think they reacted in a very
positive way because of that live demo
and getting them involved earlier in the
process Gutenberg is not released yet if
they'd waited until this thing was
merged into core and then got on stage
and showed off a polished video of the
final thing it would sort of be too late
for adoption they needed the community
to help support this effort in order for
an initiative this large to be
successful and so we see this is a the
advanced custom field steve was talking
about that a lot of folks use for those
data structures and they came in after
this state of the word at the end here
at December 2017 published a blog post
that their focus in 2018 is full
compatibility and they're focusing their
development time on that the community
started creating blog posts and articles
we looked at that map shortcode here's
was a blog post that you took the
shortcode with the square brackets you
put in a github gist URL and then it
popped out on the other side this was a
step by step development tutorial of how
to convert that to a block and and
really get getting people excited and
learning about this there's been
webinars and all sorts of things we've
been hosting some at Pantheon there's
been a lot around the community as well
as create guten block this is probably
my favorite we looked at earlier WP CLI
kind of the drush equivalent letting you
spin up a way to develop your own
block but it was vanilla JavaScript this
actually takes create RAC react app and
extends it so that you can create your
own custom block and write react code
with JSX and all the modern tools that
you want to be using and you can spin
that up in one command lowering that
barrier to entry so that people really
can get their hands on this and start
adopting the technology now before it's
actually merged into core and I went to
word camp Miami just last month in March
and so we went and there were actually
two tracks two full tracks at this
conference this is one of the larger
camps in the WordPress space has over a
thousand attendees and we saw one track
an entire day devoted to Gutenberg
development how to get started with your
first block how to take a look at those
things and a completely another track
that was just about react in ESX and
modern javascript and remember this was
a community who has largely been writing
PHP for the most part there's been some
jquery and parts of wordpress have
backbone but really to have this huge
shift from majorly writing PHP to
JavaScript
it's a really big initiative so this
community support is imperative and so
now at the end of all this we're at a
state now where Gutenberg is being still
continuing development and there's some
things that need to be worked out like
accessibility in the editor we saw that
preview of giving a warning about
accessibility on the front end well how
does a JavaScript application be
accessible for people using it working
on mobile these sorts of things but with
the community behind it and this very
large support of automatic and sort of
this being the sole focus we're at a
point where I think it can be very
successful and it's going to you know be
released when it's ready hopefully be
done right but having everybody behind
it at this stage when we're still in the
beta phase is very very important and
now WordPress is embracing this rather
than people being apprehensive and
scared when this thing comes into core
and they're already having conversations
with clients about
I'm doing a new site built for you this
new editor experience is coming let me
develop for in the develop your site
with that experience now and we'll go
back and there might be a few small
bumps but for the most part things are
fairly stable api's aren't going to
change largely they can go in and build
that and tackle those projects now so
they're not launching something that in
the next year is going to be obsolete